tous et loin tu me rappelles
j'ai toujours détesté noël comme une
prémonition
le créateur du film crazy jean-marc
balle et est décédé le soir de noël
c'est plus qu'une surprise choc
le réalisateur serait mort de causes
naturelles dans un chalet à
berthier-sur-mer près de québec cette
disparition crée un grand vide ce jour
marc singer
[Musique]
son premier long métrage liste noire en
1995 attire les regards d'elwood mais
c'est avec poésie que jean-marc valley
récolte de l'attention du monde entier
en plus de remporter dix prix génie et
13 prix jutra aujourd'hui appelée iris
au gala du cinéma québécois
une fois la vérité lui il ya d'auray les
acteurs et il était une attention
particulière au jeu des acteurs est
toujours près de la caméra le regard de
ses acteurs et entre les prises il va
leur jeter à l'oreille et ses acteurs
lui rendent bien
essayons région vejen pour lacérer
bègles et au live nicole kidman a
remporté le prix de la meilleure actrice
aux golden globes
tout comme mathieu mais konaré qui a
reçu l'oscar du meilleur acteur pour
dallas buyers club ce dernier a été le
premier film réalisé par un québécois à
être en nomination pour l'oscar du
meilleur film la mort du réalisateur
attriste l'actrice the world reese
whitherspoon qui a le coeur brisé mon
ami je t'aime envoie-t-elle sur twitter
la pianiste alexandra stréliski écrit
que jean marc vallée a été sa bonne
étoile tu es parti beaucoup trop tôt
jean marc se laisse des traces
indélébiles dans nos coeurs noam et nos
inspirations
[Musique]
le réalisateur avait choisi sa musique
pour habiller dallas buyers club entre
autres réparer le coeur humain si comme
réparer l'automobile il faut démonter
chaque pièce en mark daly a su faire sa
place parmi les plus grands cinéastes un
sens du montage incroyable une direction
d'acteurs impeccable un goût pour la
musique et l'environnement sonore mais
vraiment hors du commun pour denis
villeneuve jean marc était un ami mais
surtout un pionnier québécois dans
l'univers hollywoodien c'est immense ce
que jean marc a fait cesser ces normes
il a abattu un mur c'est come back pour
ne plus traverser entre autres grâce à
lui
le réalisateur jean marc vallée avait
encore tant à faire
[Musique]
il laisse derrière lui des oeuvres
magistrales ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal